dix jours après la mort du fondateur
d'emmaüs la fondation abbé pierre rendra
demain son rapport sur le mal-logement
elle évalue à 100 mille le nombre de
sans domicile fixe
alors que vient d'être entérinée le
droit opposable au logement nous avons
voulu revenir sur le coup de force des
enfants de don quichotte
comment en à peine plus d'un mois une
poignée de citoyens
emmenés par un jeune comédien ont-ils
réussi là où des associations avaient
jusque là échoué le dossier de soir 3
est signée bertrand boyer marteau ça
ressemble à une blague de potache un
grand barbu aux allures de sdf se jette
dans le canal saint martin à paris pour
alerter l'opinion
pour déconner
d'abord noyé dans l'internet le plongeon
d'un comédien méconnu augustin legrand
déclenché une tempête politique et
médiatique
noël approche propice à la compassion le
cadre est photogénique les médias
affluent autour du comédien qui propulsa
haute silhouette et son bagout à la une
de tous les journaux
il ya des gens qui pleurent dieu nous
voir qu'ils pleurent qu'ont compris et
il pleure il pleure dans les bras des
français qui savait pas avant et qui
savent maintenant à ce moment où est
hébergée et sortent de deux gladiateurs
baisse avec la dia tôt on vous appelle
aussi des rebelles qui prennent à témoin
l'opinion et sur cette prise à témoin
son cas pas finalement de faire bouger
de faire bouger les systèmes car ils ne
sont pas aussi prévisible quelque part
que des organisations installer une
spontanéité en dehors de toute
institution que revendique précisément
les enfants de don quichotte et malgré
cette candeur affiché en moins d'un mois
l'association obtient un plan d'urgence
70 millions d'euros et l'engagement du
chef de l'état c'est à dire faire du
droit au logement une réalité ce qu
gustin le grand art h dans la nuit au
ministère de l'emploi
une association reconnue comme atd quart
monde à l'origine du concept de droit au
logement opposable ne l'a pas obtenue
malgré cinq années de combat sans doute
aussi que atd quart monde ne fera jamais
démobilisation de ce mode là dans
lesquels on inclut des personnes qui
sont réellement à la rue parce que c'est
ça nous paraît à nous être quand même de
prendre en otage des personnes pour une
mobilisation et après qu'est ce qui se
passe
et après c'est justement la question que
pose cette importante association
lyonnaise la seule à avoir publiquement
émis des doutes sur l'action des enfants
de don quichotte la capacité
d'indignation les associations l'ont
tous les jours sur le terrain elles
n'ont elles ne sont pas entendus
pourquoi est-ce qu'elles ne sont pas
entendues sans doute parce qu'elles
travaillent trop obscurément est dans
une relation de partenariat et de
franchise et pas dans une ase dans des
actions coup d'éclat le coup d'éclat des
enfants de don quichotte porté au début
sur le seul accès au logement ont c'est
ici que la solution est beaucoup plus
complexe
après cinq ans la rue david ne serait
pas en train de s'en sortir sans un
logement certes mais aussi sans un
solide accompagnement social pour celui
qui a passé plusieurs années dans la rue
moi je sais qu'il a traversé social à
paris qui me disait qu'il fallait trois
ans pour passer dans la rue pour moi
j'en porte 15 en faire un fragile chemin
vers l'autonomie au prix d'un travail
discret pour cette association une
entreprise de longue haleine désormais
ponctuée de coups de force venue
d'ailleurs